[APPLAUSE]
AVERY SUNSHINE: Dana, can
we do "Sunday Morning?"
I just want to do a little.
My honey asked me to do this.
Y'all, I'm moving so
fast through these songs,
I'm glad I had some coffee.
Ryan, how much
time I got, honey?
I'm jamming on to one?
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
So listen, this is one
of my favorite songs,
and I decided we were going
to do something different,
so I hope you like this.
Listen.
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"SUNDAY MORNING"]
If I could whistle, I
would whistle right here.
[WHISTLES]
I can't, so I'll just
introduce Dana Johnson.
Y'all, this is Dana Johnson.
[APPLAUSE]
This is my partner.
I call him Ike Turner
Rick James Joe Jackson.
Yeah, OK.
[MUSIC - AVERY SUNSHINE,
"SUNDAY MORNING"]
[APPLAUSE]
Y'all like that?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AVERY SUNSHINE: Yeah,
I love that song.